this is Sal here and I'm at Stanford
Medical School with dr. Andy Connolly
was a pathologist year and this is the
second in our series on looking at some
of these slides yeah so we left off last
time so I'm looking at this piece here
which is normal colon we had said this
is an example of what you'd see it at
the edge of a specimen Richard rollin
cancer now I'm going to click to the
next one which is slightly more
worrisome areas yes your pathologists
looking through the colon and so I'm
going to zoom in just a little bit here
to take a look at these looks very
worrisome compared to the last one and
so what we don't like about it is we saw
before this is what the normal gland
right right it's a test tube shape and
goes down and it has these cells which
are normal now all of a sudden it looks
a little thicker here and what catches
our eye also these aren't just straight
test tubes and right right they divide
they kind of go in and out like that
right so but they still are test tubes I
did following up what we said in the
last video is that they just look like
circles as opposed to test tubes because
we're taking a cross-section because
they're kind of popping out of that out
of the two dimension that's right but
although when you come from the surface
here and you go down or either they
normally should never branch
I see so these ones are branches and
that's always bad right and then you can
see the way when your cross putting a
cross section there's normally just a
little hole in the middle right and
that's where the mucin you can see even
see it spilling out Wow Wow so you can
see it just kind of coming right out of
there this one here looks different and
what it is it's piled up right and so
it's a little bit bigger around and in
order for these cells there's you know
more cells they're going to be all piled
up and going like this and they even
branch and so what this is is that we
look a little more closely at this piece
and we say hmmm I wonder if that's
cancer
could it be pre cancer or just just an
area of irritation and a common response
of the body right to irritation is some
sort of change right and like we were
saying before epithelium right is the
top layer right right and so if it's
missing the outside world basically
outside world so it's irritated often
the epithelium will change in this case
it's changing by under growing more
growth is it always even if it's not
cancer
like it's going to be a higher
likelihood that's going to become
cancerous in the future a lot of cancers
it appears in the body come from parts
of the body that are either irritated or
have some sort of environmental
challenges like constantly at them and
part of that is because there's a lot of
cell division I say if you keep dividing
a cell you might have error either so
that's why skin cells bowel cells that's
right
and even things like liver if you keep
damaging your liver you might have on
doing things in liver cancer right so
when you're looking here we would the
pathologist would look at this area and
say well it's a dividing gland that's
kind of thrown up in these areas but
largely they're still making mucin or
they're this type here which looks like
it's tall and probably absorbing water
I see so even within these test tubes
there are these well not really test
tubes but inside of these vessels there
are also the still the absorbs the
absorptive cells as well that's right so
so here this is we would sign this off
as hyperplasia hyperplasia so hyper like
too much of something yep and then
pleasure growth growth I see and so
pleasure just means growth and so hyper
pleasure means too much growth but the
important thing is if you took away the
irritant or I wouldn't do this
I see so if you took away whatever the
irritant is for the hyperplasia it would
go back to being normal
I see I see and this is something we
know that that's right and there's some
stimulus that was causing this this
these cells to do that it might even die
it might have been some chemical that
could have been yeah we're never really
sure what and because so much of it is
things that just float on through I come
through so it's really hard to to know
but yeah this is probably too much
growth eye response too so it's possible
that you know it just happened to be
when this dissection of the cold was
taken out if this was done a day later
maybe then maybe this might have not
been there yeah probably take a longer
than a couple couple weeks a couple of
weeks but what happens is that the cells
come from the bottom and they worked
their way up towards the top ice
eventually the top with ice it behaved
and so the way the body works here it's
kind of like the skin is use this as
constant these cells are being used up
because things have been kind of
scraping by them and and they had a lot
of kind of use they do in fact a
constant stream there's a lot known out
about stem cells and the stem cells for
the intestine are these guys oh wow so
you had a different sheet this there's
there's a at the very bottom the bottom
hemisphere there are going to be cells
there that do not have the open
chromatin I kind of elongated there may
be ones which are endocrine cells right
meaning they release hormones right and
so they may have hormone releasing cells
but in this bottom hemisphere right that
turns out to be where the intestine
keeps them and these guys are probably
these just as a stem cells are under
front cells that haven't kind of picked
their jobs yet they haven't and so
there's all kinds of stem cells there's
the stem cell that can make a whole body
being exactly but then there's also the
kind that can make the rest of the cult
I see right so this one is probably the
stem cell that can make the rest of the
epithelium right there are two different
kinds or two different types right yeah
so they're down here at the bottom
that's about where you'd want it exactly
sorry right right so so that makes sense
so down there are your stem cells and it
grows like that so this is a hyperplasia
Wow so I'd like to show you next the
next step which is the pre cancer lesion
okay do that in another video this is in
another video okay